i'd like to get an updated 2021 version
of
michael miles giving advice to young
people
okay
so there's
god forbid
high school students college students
listening to you
uh and looking to you for advice what
advice would you give them about career
and about life how to live a life they
can be proud of this happens a lot
because i have my locals community
malice.locals.com and there's a lot of
young people in there yeah so that's a
great place i'll give i'll give them a
meta piece of advice don't ask your
friends for advice because you're an
idiot at your age and they're all idiots
and they don't want to seem like idiots
so they're just going to give you advice
they pulled it from the tv and no one
knows what you're talking about and it's
just going to be counterintuitive so
seek out advice from people
who
you seek to emulate
and ask them for advice if you can't get
a hold of them figure out a way to get a
hold of them
incentivize them in some way
you'd be surprised how many people are
responsive on twitter or in social media
if you just ask them a basic life
question because then they can quote
tweet an answer to a whole population so
that would be one mechanism
it's also very hard at that age to
realize your parents might not
be all that bright and they might not be
all that good people
um so that's a hard one at that age to
kind of wrap your head around just
because they love you doesn't mean they
understand you and that's okay
that's that's okay
we think everybody
oh [ __ ] you're trump's pretty good too i
i i'd like your
trump to talk to elon
conversation
well mr president you know look uh
some things you did like some
not so much but you know for the most
part i think the kind of good thing what
are you talking about
um
hey guys what are you guys what are we
talking about [ __ ] i [ __ ] up the lex
anyway so that those would be two pieces
the other piece of advice i would say is
join a gym
or have some kind of
quantifiable
daily improvement
to keep you sane so the reason i always
say weightlifting and it could be
running it could be jump rope i don't
care what it is because if you have
those numbers moving in the positive
direction psychologically if you're
dealing with depression or anxiety it's
concrete proof to shut your brain up
because your brain
knows how to talk to you your brain is
off on your enemy and i'll say exactly
the right thing to undermine you so
that's an issue um b
i just this works for me maybe it
weren't for most people i'm very high in
the openness metric
uh try new experiences new things try
things you don't like
it's okay to have a bad experience
you've learned something
so go to a restaurant of a cuisine you
wouldn't like or hadn't heard of read a
book that's popular but you have no
interest in
read a lot for example i didn't know
anything about the
uh election what was it 1892 when there
was like a split between the electors
read a book about it oh i don't know
anything you know i know anything really
about malcolm x read a book about him uh
you'll be amazed how much
more full you become as a person do you
see value in writing also like writing
down your ideas no i think there's very
little value in that i'm not being i'm
not joking so reading is where the
biggest yeah because you're probably not
going to revisit what you've written
down
um but the act of writing you don't you
don't see it solidify somehow thoughts
in your mind not for me
it doesn't like a tweet will because
then then i have to have it narrowed
down into like a phrase or the
responsibility of there being an
audience
no i just meant in terms of i've got 280
characters if instead of having a
briendry thought meandering thought i
have to codify it in something that's
catchy and short that's a good useful
mental exercise what face do you make
when you tweet
i wouldn't know i don't know that's a
good point i'll is it on the toilet how
much what percentage is on the toilet
very little on the toilets i usually
more reading okay um so even though my
tweets are all literally [ __ ] uh the
very few of them are on the toilet
um they're on a throne that's some
advice um
don't compare yourself to other people
that's a really dangerous one
all my friends are married i should have
i should have a kid by
should there's an expression in recovery
stop shooting yourself
but it's but it should should yeah it's
stupid yeah
i also and this could be my hoarder
brain
i surround my house with talismans of
joy
so if you have an accomplishment
like when i did rogan once
i bought with the sock store and i
bought these orange socks with black
cherries on them and now whenever i wore
that socks those socks i'm like oh this
is because i was on rogan that was kind
of a big deal so if you have these
little things throughout your house
it gives good mental fuel even like like
a toy remember when i was a kid oh you
know what this
little moments that inspire happiness i
think are visually very useful
um
so that's another one um
and i by the way have the
that the watch
and um that because we're talking about
2021
that was really um
the guy in the lecture hall giving you a
pat in the back i wrote uh joe giving me
the the watch
was um
he has life changing for me yeah yeah
yeah it doesn't even it didn't the fact
that it was on a podcast or whatever
doesn't matter learn how to
uh um form boundaries that's probably
the biggest that's gonna be number one
on my list
because you'll explain you're gonna have
people around you who feel the need that
they're entitled to your time who feel
the need to criticize you and they're
not coming from a good place yeah uh so
it's very good for you to be like i'm
not interested in talking about this
anymore right now yeah uh even if it's
your parents even if it's your
especially if it's your parents like i
need my space right now you're entitled
to your space you're entitled to your
time no one owes you you don't owe
anyone response uh if someone has a
question you know them an answer
especially if they're not coming at you
in good faith or they're coming in
hostile way
that's a big one
it's hard to learn at that age um
and um
and and
be valuable
to
those who are around you
be someone who people are happy to see
and
if things are bad like you're the one
that they can rely on
like i was just uh you know a little bit
under the weather and i thought to
myself you know what if things got
really bad i'll call blair
and she would take care of me and and
that kind of was very reassuring
and you can always call me if you have
your stuff lifted in
in
in an urgent matter because of the
robots no just me it's kind of like
that's those things that can help with
or you're actually literally bleeding
not a good caretaker i can save you
though i can murder if you need somebody
murdered yeah
yeah yeah
um
wait what advice would you have to kids
that age
and you're all you're a lot younger than
you think you are that's the other one
like yeah there's time i know
like it's impossible to understand when
you're 26 that your 40s are better than
your 30s because like okay old man
you're that's all cope
i promise you it is
yeah i i think uh he says so many
beautiful things i i would say
another version of the openness i'll say
take big risks when you're young yeah
because if you fail who cares you're
sleeping it's not in a futon who cares
yeah and take them often yeah um
also this is more a little personal to
me
i get pushback on this but i think
take big risks and work really hard
like at whatever you do like i think you
just have to give yourself to a thing it
doesn't have to be in terms of time but
really give everything so it's not like
i'm going to try
doing this i'll try i'll try
try
with all of your heart
like really commit yourself that doesn't
mean necessarily ours that doesn't mean
but like if you fail at doing a thing
that you commit to
it should hurt
so like when i competed in jiu jitsu or
you do like sports and so on don't just
say i'm gonna have fun out there so on
no try to win
and because then if you don't it hurts
and you learn from that
and then throughout i think that's the
goodness thing is be kind
it's like
some of it is also skill allowing
yourself to be kind i found myself
earlier in life i still do this
i find like when i hang out with people
people are often like cynical and
negative
and yeah i try to avoid those people no
but like they i think everybody falls
into that
and sometimes it's the party norm thing
there's a temptation to me
to kind of fit in by being more negative
than i'm comfortable being and so
um
resist the pressure i think especially
when you're younger it's not cool to
care
the thing that drives when you're young
if you are a fan of a band yeah a writer
a podcast or an actor and people roll
their eyes at you
watch out those people are dangerous you
should have it's if you love avril
lavigne
with her terrible music and she makes
you gives you joy and people crap on you
they're wrong and you're right
so hold on to those things that make you
happy and if people want to take that
away from you or they how could you like
that what those people are not your
friends
why do you have to go make life so
complicated
my she's my favorite um
favorite musician of all time
jimi hendrix secondary living first
um thank you for almost bringing a deer
to my
you